okay we got our next episode Lake insert
mispronounced word here got mavica try
that one you know avatar you're doing so
good with the titles I can pronounce and
now Lake laogai is that it loud Gale our
guy opens oh I don't care you're gonna
yell me the countess regardless so okay
so we got this episode here this is the
one where um they get upper back yay
Appa's finally bagged it's as nice a
good reunion but the trials are getting
him back are pretty crazy and you find
out more and more about just how
disturbed and fucked up this city is
that they're in that seems to be the
running theme is that the earth Kingdom
is fucking insane
or the earth was a good yeah the earth
Kingdom yeah I I don't know why the
earth Kingdom is specifically this
insane but may they'll go into it maybe
it's just that's it the fucking and
saying I don't know but they have this
very creepy underground world uh which
is sir like don't drink the water kind
of thing away for different reasons um
and to me the surf felt like I don't
know necessarily the darkest but some of
the darkest elements because you simply
have you know it's one thing when you
kill a character when somebody dies oh
no they'll never come back and that said
there's something scarier about taking
away somebody's mind and that's some of
the freakiest stuff and you get the
return of was a Judy I think was her
name and I think they were implying
before that they killed her off so I'm
almost wondering if it I don't think
they won't gotten notes on that or maybe
the studio came down and said hey you
can't kill up Judy bring her back uh so
she does come back from the vacation and
she says um but I think it's more just
to show hey she's still alive you know
we didn't actually kill her so but we do
find out there's millions of Judy's I
think that's the scariest scene is we
see all these Judy's lined up and it's
just like you know my name is Judy my
name is Judy
is let me get this that weird wide-angle
shot that they like to do in this show
which is effective by the way when they
do those wide-angle shots um but you get
that you have jets return and for a
little bit it doesn't last very long
although you never see him die uh so
maybe he's still around
it ends with his two compadres whatever
sort of guarding him knowing he's gonna
get axed off but they want to stay with
him and go down with deep underground
lair
so yeah it's I guess we find out more
that the earth king does not know
exactly what's going on and he's kept
he's kept in secret out of the loop and
you have the this Battle of first trying
to get Appa back and then probably my
guess would be if not telling them
what's going on with the with the clips
telling somebody else but it seems like
the biggest people to tell it seems like
they would have to tell this kingdom and
but we haven't seen the earth King yet I
mean so it's they had to introduce him
whether he's real or not or he's just a
puppet or if he's just a bow figure of
it figuratively and literally I think it
might be interesting really is a puppet
okay just bring him out Joe then and
take him away um so yeah I guess we're
tapping into that creepy stuff of not
necessarily trusting everybody and
everything especially in a city this
large I mean it's that so much of
government is fascinating that way how I
mean don't get me wrong I'll just I have
no control over what people do in the
higher-ups or maybe I do if I fought
hard enough but I don't understand
politics I'm not going to pretend I do
I'm one of those dumb Americans that's
just like you know what okay just don't
kill me or attack me or anything I'll
try to live my life you try to destroy
ours but yeah here's an example of it
just pushed to the ultimate degree and
of course one a time to watch it after
we got the whole thing with the
whistleblower and they're listening done
yeah
all of us and everything which is I mean
which sucks but I really that shocked
guy he really that shocked um I'm
getting all political here uh so yeah
I'm trying what's a comment I really I
get you do have Zuko totally
now abandoning the Fire Nation and the
Blue Spirit outfit which by the way
somebody did point out I didn't know
this because I said where did he get
that blue spirit mask from Magana come
on he was blown out of the ship and
everything I guess they had a scene this
is just going by somebody's comment
where they passed I guess a guy with a
card of masks like pass by and one of
them was the Blue Spirit but was very
quickly so I just oh that's clever stuff
if that's true I haven't gone back to
jacket but if that's true that's very
cool um so he's given that up which is
great I'm wondering where they're gonna
go now with it um with the Zuko care
Danny we still have a whole other season
coming up and obviously he's a big part
um but yeah I that I of course would
like to see where he goes I liked seeing
the uncle uh pull him out of it I was
wondering what he was gonna do to Appa
if anything or if he was just gonna wait
for the Avatar to come in um so I wasn't
sure what the plan was I thought when
did that really been like a heart rip
out your chest didn't like you be killed
off all my galinha than the words but
they get him back and they have the nice
reunion he gives them the great big hug
and they have a nice little fight too
with um with Appa throwing the guy
across the the ocean that I love they
skipped across that was wonderful
um so yeah I guess with this episode not
that not too much else to talk about I
I'd be lying if I said I wouldn't miss
jet that much I just look character
never did anything for me um and he did
just sort of seem like a pawn just to
get across certain elements you know
just show how crazy this city is or how
far somebody can take go after the Fire
Nation I don't know he he just seems
like a plot
nice to me but I mean not not the worst
plot device I've seen worse but you know
just it compared to the other characters
he doesn't seem that fascinating so if
he is gone yeah I didn't see too much in
any way but may he'll come back and
he'll be even better and it'll be even
more fascinating so who knows uh that's
about it I can't think of too much else
to say about this one I'm curious what
they're gonna do with the next one I
hope they do address what the earth king
is if he is just a guy who's left in the
dark and why or if he's just a puppet or
a you know like something that's
literally like a cardboard cutout and
why that too so I'm curious to see where
that goes and that's about it I'll see
you at the next one end we'll see where
that goes